une poignée d'irréductibles gaulois
continue de rides au père de l'aigle
impérial leur forêt à déboiser vous
pourrez soit dans l'oeil jusqu'au
cubitus raisin la ferme cubitus os j'ai
découvert il ya une semaine
* c'est super se déroule mieux que prévu
c'est ma jeunesse j'ai adoré je crois
qu'on est nés la même année astérix et
moi astérix vraiment pas photo c'est un
rapport direct à la petite enfance
je crois qu'on a tous été un peu élevés
à la potion vous le monde et des
services offrant non
le luxe de ceux de cet astérix là c'est
qu'on a opposé nos voiliers plusieurs
mois maintenant où les dessins n'était
pas fait en tout cas il y avait des
vraies bonnes dès les 1 j'ai presque
choisi les comédiens avant d'écrire
comme ça les répliques étaient de bien
fait pour eux et l'animation à les
suivre
il réplique enregistrée donc tout ça
allait partir en fait de l'envi des
acteurs c'est la chance d'enregistrer en
français c'est à dire que la voie est
maîtresse et directrice de toute
l'animation derrière il est comme un
chef d'orchestre en fait il est plutôt
dans la musique des mots donc il est
très précis à propos de quoi
d'une manière générale je vous ai
compris animations et un soutien mais un
boulot formidable sur le film qui est
vraiment très très très agréable à
regarder et joyeux et c'est communicatif
c'est un travail titanesque
c'est incroyable et si on colle aux
romains une partie général voilà c'était
ça mon idée c'est vraiment la rencontre
aussi louis clichy alexandre astier
astérix avec le clichy c'est une jolie
rencontre parce qu'elle est très très
animé ces cas le lien qui sera aussi le
bon côté
la motivation reste intacte ont bien
tous les deux un monde extrêmement
différents lui c'est un échiquier
d'aller chez pixar tronche en annulation
un des challenge très important de ce
film c'était de respecter de voir ce
qu'allait donner astérix obélix le
village en fête tout l'univers d'uderzo
en images de synthèse et en relief par
bus du dégât
j'ai trouvé ça très drôle n'appuie c'est
un vrai film d' aventure c'est
transgénérationnel je savais que ce
serait savoureux mélange de toute
évidence moi je suis très fan
d'alexandre astier tout autant que
d'astérix et de la modernité
il ya de l'originalité en même temps il
respecte le scénario original on
retrouve le plaisir de l'album le
plaisir d'un grand film d'animation et
le l'univers d'alexandre astier
ça c'est formidable
ah ça n'est pas que la même limonade